bruno c'est vrai que là j'ai des
questions à vous poser parce que cette
soir on a du mal à y croire
mine de rien fait on a du mal à croire
que des policiers se jette sur quelqu'un
pour rien s'ils passent à tabac est ce
que c'est
des affaires qui ont déjà eu à ce qu'on
a déjà eu
voilà des précédents des affaires de
violence des poules de la part des
policiers ça existe il faut pas le nier
le personnel a nié d'ailleurs ni les
syndicats ni la police mais façon
générale il faut savoir quand même et ça
va mettre un petit peu dans lequel que
en france il ya trois millions
d'interventions par an des policiers 3
millions c'est pas rien mais là sur les
3 millions il y en a qui dérape
elles sont pas nombreuses mais là vous
avez un classé plus qu'un dérapage temps
le dira oui celui de vous l'expliquer
qu'on voulait mais pour moi c'est un
dérapage de très grave évidemment qui
était à l'origine juste content
nationale puisque ce monsieur ne portait
pas masquer mon à la limite comme tout
le monde il y aurait pu prendre sur une
contravention c'était hélas il ya eu un
dérapage et on est passés dans des faits
de violence et en réunion à caractère
raciste avec des policiers en fonction
et c'est bon c'est une catastrophe
évidemment pour la police nationale 2
face aux énormes qu'elle est quel est le
sentiment de la police aujourd'hui sur
ça mais écoutez moi j'ai passé un long
moment cet après midi un coup même
métier parce que ce matin j'étais chez
mon collègue steve j'ai eu des retours
catastrophé de l'ensemble des policiers
même mes copains du raid pour ça ils
sont un petit peu à l'écart pour mody le
rêve se battait un gorille ou disons à
l'est de la wilaya sont des gens
exceptionnels moi je vois là j'ai la
chance deux tiennent leur ai dit avoir
rencontré plein et qui sont qui veulent
juste faire leur boulot et c'est
vraiment ils font un travail
exceptionnel ils s'entraînent comme des
fous et ça ça leur fait vraiment pas
passé loin de là c'est la catastrophe
pour la pêche et la question tous les
gens qui connaissent un désert au café
la police ou la première sert à 6,1
police est violente et la police n'est
pas comme ça si vous savez très bien
tous manière vous l'avez remarqué très
justement hier et michel l'a fait et ça
c'est bien parce qu'avec la haine qu'ils
pouvaient avoir envisagé la police il a
été très mesuré dans les nouvelles sont
là bruno c'est comme dans tout il ya 95%
debout et à 5% bien mauvais mais qui
fera énormément de mal mais 95% je sais
bruno 98 pour ce 10 81 18,7 pour cent -
puisqu'on est dans les chiffres de
l'opération qui se passe normalement
mais c'est quoi ça qu'est ce qu'ils se
sont dit et les policiers bella et
taylor
leur but c'est pas qu'ils sont sûrs ce
nirvana
ils ont pété les plombs c'est les mecs
se dopait manque de discernement total
ils ont perdu les ils ont perdu les mâts
comme aucune aucune aucune maîtrise de
la situation allait provoquer du début
on l'a on l'a vu un monsieur papa la
police on sait ça que ça dérape c'est
que ces caractéristiques de la cedh et
violences volontaires
alors donc ça veut dire qu'il y avait un
sentiment d'impunité quand même parce
que c'est celle à la question c'est ce
sentiment d'impunité
valérie je sais pas c'est des mecs qui
n'ont rien à faire chez nous ça c'est
sûr mais qui ont pété les plombs et
pourquoi l enquête veut être le dira
aussi attention que je il faut faire
quand même une parenthèse à tout ça et
c'est pas pour t'assurer savonnerie pas
les faits qu'ils ont commis ces gens là
il ya la présomption d'innocence faut
pas l'oublier on a une constitution en
france on a une loi on a des lois elles
sont faites pour tout le monde même pour
les pires cancer même pour les serial
killers est à présent sur d'innocence et
laissons faire la justice la justice
donnera je pense des éléments probants
de ce qui s'est réellement passé
mais il est évident que la dent les
taxes et les choses évidemment ces
policiers mais pour être inculpé ça sent
la question tourne se pose est celle que
je vois c'est un gars de vue d'ailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux et à la plaque
urnes ont parlé dont benjamin mendy mon
pote antoine griezmann kylie ann m bape
et dites moi s'il n'y avait pas eu les
caméras ça se serait passé comment pour
michel eeckhout et il aurait porté
plaine c'est évident il ya des coups et
blessures volontaires on l'a vu
puisqu'il a été marquée il est blessé il
a eu une itt était de 8 jours non
nécessairement non mais c'était toujours
aujourd'hui en jour il s'étire entre
autres jours non je n'ai vu que des
bustes et sinon la parole des policiers
n'est pas systématiquement plus sorte il
ne faut pas croire ça attention il ya
d'abord des témoins pour ça que l'
enquête a duré les policiers qui sont
venus enquêter sur l'environnement
c'est-à-dire tous les gens qui sont
autour qui ont vu donc il ya des témoins
qui peut visuel qui se permettent qu ils
peuvent dire des choses sont pressés
verbal qui peuvent annoncer évidemment
ce qui a été réellement commises sur le
sur le terrain donc non je pense que des
faits aussi graves comme ça ne serait
pas passé à l'acte
à mon sens ne serait jamais passé
il ya plein de célébrités qui ont tenu à
faire référence à cette affaire
aujourd'hui regardez petit laquelle vous
allez nous dire ce que vous en pensez
que j'aime et bruno vous nous donnerez
d'autres éléments
également il vous aider nous dire ce que
risquent ces policiers bien entendu
c'est pas hier la vidéo de
l'interpellation extrêmement violente de
michel dans le xviie arrondissement de
paris a fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
sur instagram des milliers d'internautes
ont publié des scories des images
insoutenables de ces policiers
visiblement déchaîné des internautes
dont de nombreuses stars comme le
footballeur antoine griezmann qui a
réagi à ces images j'ai mal à ma france
même indignation du côté de kindia
n'aime pas p qui a commenté vidéo
insoutenable violence inadmissible stop
au racisme
reprenant ensuite les paroles de la
chanson de diam's ma france à moi le
basketteur rudy gobert a quant à lui
lancé un appel à continuer à dénoncer
les violences continuent et a tout filmé
ce qu'ils font bien leur boulot aurons
une bonne image et les lâchers menteur
continueront d'être exposé que ça soit
d'un sens ou d'un autre aya nakamura de
son côté a posté un message pour saluer
les gens qui ont filmé et peut-être
sauvé la vie de michel merci aux caméras
et courage à michel benjamin biolay date
joué beaucoup d'autres stars se sont
elles aussi indigné de telles violences
alors elle advient d'eux reçoit aussi un
message d'un ami qui me dit encore merci
pour les images de michèle et bernard
laporte qui seront dans clic ce dimanche
sur canal+ deux des plus gros interview
de l'année bravo je t'aime fort c'est
mon ami mouloud qui est vraiment un gars
que j'aime et qui est un gars voilà
c'est le plus grand le plus cool de
france et qui fait pour moi les
meilleures interviews du paf et j'ai
fait un énorme bisou à mouloud oui moi
j'ai juste une question je crois que
vous avez travaillé sur le plan quartier
1 va écraser itunes quartier beaucoup
dans les quartiers comment vous faites à
des images pareilles quand comment vous
pouvez expliquer aux jeunes des
banlieues
bien sûr il faut pas caricaturer il faut
pas généraliser mais comment vous avez
communiquer avec ça ben je vais je vais
ramener mois j'accueille 45 mille
enfants parents où j'essaie de
transmettre évidemment ces valeurs la
république à tous ces gamins de quartier
a beaucoup de gamins du quartier et je
me bats avec 250 policiers sur le
terrain tous les jours pour ça et je
peux vous assurer que c'est pas simple
mais on le fait ce genre de tir de
d'action évidemment pour moi nuit n'est
nécessairement à tout ce que je fais
depuis 30 ans voilà aujourd'hui depuis
30 ans bruno que c'était des conseils
des stars qui ravissent y paraît que ça
vous plaît pas ouais ça me plaît pas du
tout non sincèrement les stars devraient
faire comme vous avez fait cyril c'est
de mesurer les propos toujours et ne pas
jouer les stars ces gens là vivent dans
un autre monde dans une enseigne penser
que ça mais ça me met hors de moi très
sincèrement mais oui parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils attisent la haine c'est du
soutien pour michel moi je vois ça de
façon beaucoup plus global et il faut
pas voir si le prisme juste de michel
c'est certain ce qui s'est passé c'est
très bien mais il faudrait aussi qu
logiquement il est très touché
si la masse mais je préfère les propos
que vous avez eue sur le plateau vous
être regardée par des centaines de
milliers de personnes pour dire
attention ne faisons pas l'amalgamme
griezmann qui jouent super bien au
football aurait dû sûrement dire ça
attention ne faisons pas la main de
l'homme c'est lamentable ce qu'ont fait
ces trois policiers c'est tout voilà
j'ai croisé des policiers hier c'est
scandaleux on rentre on est rendu du
studio qui m'ont arrêté parce que bâchée
je te demandais si voilà pourquoi
j'étais truc donc j'avais bien sûr elles
sont ici rec même eux ils m'ont dit pour
eux c'est une catastrophe
voilà je vous le dis donc l'ensemble de
la police pour eux ça ce genre de 2-2-2
voilà deux catastrophes match est une
catastrophe pour eux c'est un drame
parce que dise comment on va faire notre
travail derrière
il déteste ce genre de comportement la
plupart et c'est vrai que c'est un drame
pose c'est de ça qu'il ne faut pas
rajouter surtout avec des stars comme ça
n'est ce qu'un policier se fait laminer
monsieur griezmann et toute la clique
des stars griezmann c'est un super g et
la corse et les ont pas du tout celle
des stations dans les deux dernières
michel jeffrey mais il faut le faire le
[Musique]
plein de gens voient la très sérieuse
ils attendent dit ça pose aussi un vrai
problème c'est des gens qui sont uniques
qui sont très célèbre et qui n'ont pas
recours aux tweets et moi aujourd'hui
j'ai entendu des gens dire tu vois
maintien intel comme par hasard il n'a
pas fait de tweets il n'a pas fait de
tweets
or moi je sais que c'est des gens qui
sont largement aussi sensible que ce ça
que cela mais qui n'ont pas recours à ça
et qui tombe par pudeur n'aime pas avoir
recours à savoir moi je suis d'accord
message final de michel de michel meyer
est le vôtre
c'était exactement twitté ça et s'en
tenir à ça mais moi je pense sincèrement
qu'ils n'attise pas nécessairement à la
haine et quand je suis désolé mais quand
vous vous dites que toutes ces stars
vivent dans un autre monde vous
généralisez ses stars donc en soi alors
j'imagine c'est sa saison
ça m'a choqué dans le sens où évidemment
qu'il ne faut pas généraliser tous les
policiers parce qu'ils ont une portée
non mais ces gens ont évidemment qu'ils
ont une portée énorme mais c'est pas
qu'ils étaient à rennes c'est juste qui
ils soutiennent du coup michel et
soutiennent un peu sa dernière chance
sociale cette histoire horrible mais ils
ne font pas une généralisation et 6,6
sur le vidéo qui réagit à ce que vous
dites et qui dit salut syrie 10 de
regrettable que les images n'ont pas les
mêmes d'un pacte pour tous ceux qui ont
subi des violences policières
beaucoup d'idées jaunes ont été filmés
pendant les violences policières et ont
pas eu le même traitement que michel les
violences policières existe bel et bien
qu'on le veuille ou non de mon soutien à
toutes les victimes
alors c'est vrai que là je veux pas m'en
confesse mirarchi victimes
diallo moi je suis à fond bien sûr vous
le savez avec tous ceux qui ont été
touchés parmi les gilets jaunes d'oeufs
dont jérôme le pauvre qui a perdu un
oeil mais michel ce qu'il a vécu aussi
c'est extrêmement rare et bien voilà
observant qu'il manque en somme un doute
dans son bureau et il se fait attaquer
xv ème ou pays riches et massacré bon
rien
et il dit ilic aussi qu'aucune victime
aucune star n'avait twitté pour les 30
éborgné des gilet jaune donne surtout et
un cd rom rodriguez voilà qui est un
garçon qui a perdu un oeil
mine de rien leur demander voilà mais il
ne faut pas dramatiser je pense voilà la
souffrance
michel a énormément souffert sur galets
gilet jaune qui ont énormément souffert
pendant les manifs je le dis et qu'ils
ont perdu voilà trente et born in pour
rendez compte que ccc oui et non ces
deux sujets différents
onovo mars et 26 avril est différent
parce que michel il rentrait lui pas
vraiment l'algérie bon mais même pas
voir de policiers devaient rentrer chez
lui tranquillement et à la limite c'est
ça lui est passé aïe ça et puis surtout
simple là c'est un fait vraiment à part
c'est à dire que là il est tout seul
l'actualité on n'y a pas trop de à part
locaux vides on parle pas trop
d'agressions assure sert donc c'est
normal que pour les il est jeune et
quand tu as beaucoup de personnes qui se
font agresser par la police m'a traité
effectivement il ya des personnes qui
sont passées à la trappe
il savait pas dire pour autant qu'on
sous-estimé c'est inadmissible pour les
gilet jaune et gilet jaune et moi je
peux vous dire tous les soirs voilà
quand je pense à jérôme c'est un crève
coeur bien parce que eh bien si voilà si
ça me fait ça me fait énormément et
celles ci ont ensuite un col à moi
personnellement je croyais que je
considère ce ne sont pas des policiers
est ce que j'aimerais ma question
j'aimerais vous poser c'est comment
aujourd'hui savez comment vous expliquer
qu'aujourd'hui ça puisse exister
est ce que c'est un poignet de formation
c'est un problème d'argent
c'est ce que c'est un problème de
contrôle parce que cette image elle est
effrayante et en majorité 99 % les
policiers ne sont pas comme ça à ce que
l'un pour moi c'est qu'à l'époque ils
disposaient les téléspectateurs et les
victimes ils disent qu'ils se croient
tout permis et et là ça c'est un
raccourci mais en même temps pour des
cobayes se croient tout permis
les propos que vous avez eue avec michel
lire mesure est encore une fois bien sûr
on pourrait montrer mais c'est aucun
intérêt évidemment des policiers qui
sauvent quelqu'un dans un accident de la
route ayant des petits sauve quelqu'un
qui se fait agresser dans la rue il y en
a fait un tout le monde s'en fout non
mais tu montes action immédiate mais je
veux dire ça c'est toujours et ses 98
1,7 pour cent des interventions des
policiers ils font leur métier
la chasse est pas dire oui il apprend
tous les jours mais elles sont nicolas
pernikoff savait que les policiers
représentent à la société actuelle
moi je rentre il ya 36 ans dans la
police les profils le profil que de
représenter il ya 36 ans et pas les
mêmes profils de jeunes comment c'est
tout simplement le profil de la société
actuelle déjà bon ça c'est d'une
première chose dans la formation il ya
huit mois de formation peut-être un peu
court mais pourquoi pas avec moi sur le
terrain a fait 16 mois
est-ce que c'est assez ou pas les
contenus sont quand même assez
conséquent au niveau de la police en
termes de formation à voir je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose à revoir mon sens
c'est dans l'affectation des policiers
trop jeune dans des secteurs alors là
c'est le 17e arrondissement mais je
prends le de l'ensemble des quartiers
par exemple la politique de la ville de
mettre des gens d'expérience et nsa ya
très longtemps qu'on lit on dit toujours
la même chose ça me paraît essentielle
et deuxième chose qui me paraissent
essentiels mais ça va se généraliser ces
les caméras piétons j'y crois totalement
absurde et qu'elle lui disais c'est là
dessus ç'a fonctionné parce que ça oui
le fossat permis aux décors oui ok ce
qui risque c'est dix ans de prison mais
ils sont cinquante mille euros damende
aurait dix ans de prison et quand même
sens et 4000 euros de langue mais c'est
une segmentation vous avez lancé en
réunion armée représentant l'ordre
public en plus d'eau qui est fait
aggravant c'est très très grave des
matches prévus ils sont défendables ou
pas du tout ça va être compliqué de
trouver des trouver des justificatifs à
cette action ça va être un peu compliqué
pour vous non je pense que
l'administration là dessus ne va pas les
aider
si ces matches d'abord parce que la
protection juridictionnelle
malheureusement qu'il ya ça on lâche les
policiers alors des fois on les lâche à
mauvais escient parce qu'ils méritent
vraiment d'être protégé là dans ce cas
là effectivement il ne mérite pas c'est
aussi un problème pour eux parce que ces
gens là vont se retrouver vivant à l'eau
est ce que pourrait nous dire ce soir on
dort en direct sur ses beats est ce que
vous avez déjà entendu des policiers
partir il se dire tiens on va aller
bastonner avait lors du black façon je
voulais je vous dise hier il y avait
l'avocate de michel et elle m'a dit oui
moi je suis sûr qu'ils sont partis sont
dit tiens on va les taper un mec voilà
où
l'interdît salle le soir elle a dû rêver
la nuit peut-être mais non mais je
trouve que c'est facile mais ce que ça
arrive ça mais surhumain sûrement à
cyril mais évidemment mais encore une
fois c'est l'essence économie le
policier moi je suis incroyable travail
et je sais c'est pas à dire allez on va
se faire les voyons va se faire les
blacks on va se faire c'est pas ici mais
d'un tout mais de manière assidue
l'existoire tout va bien sûr que la
veille voilà mes jeux parce que voilà
j'ai encore une fois c'est ces cas qui
sont mineurs heureusement évidemment
dans notre société sont sont sanctionnés
mais durement diriez vous avez été chef
du raid qui selon leurs dires yacé à ses
policiers
je les prendrais sur le ring qu'est ce
qu'une paire de gants de boxe et je le
recevrai quelques petites séries de 20
ans voulait oublier vous leur dites quoi
bah c'est ce que scandaleux il faut les
traiter plus bas que terre parce que
c'est c'est catastrophique dans toute
une pour tout métier c'est ça la
ministre thériault gardiens de la paix
de base dont je suis issue et moi je
trouve ça scandaleux
c'est terrible pour notre organisme de
l'intérieur il était chez anne sophie
lapix hier il a réagi regardez si les
jeux sont inqualifiables
elles sont extrêmement choquantes et dès
que j'ai pris connaissance de celle ci
est ce qui s'était passé j'ai demandé la
suspension de ces policiers et dès que
les faits seront établis par la justice
puisqu'elle est saisie je demanderai la
révocation de ces policiers qui l'ont
sali l'uniforme de la république et si
encore une fois la justice démontrent en
effet ces faits qui font peu de doute
alors oui nous devrons plus porter cet
uniforme ils seront révoqués la police
nationale lorsqu'à des gens qui déconne
ils doivent quitter l'uniforme de la
république ils doivent être sanctionnés
ils doivent quitter ce travail ils
doivent être punis par la justice
alors vous avez vu déconne voilà c'est
ça qui a qui est choqué parce que c'est
plus que déconner la c1
c'est vrai que là c'est plus que des
fois on regarde à moi ce que je voulais
dire ce qui m'a énormément ému hier soir
c'est la qualité de ceux de sept hommes
de michel était extraordinaire je suis
le mec en a pris plein la gueule et dans
son discours il dit je leur en veux pas
c'est pas tout la police qui est comme
ça je suis allé vers un service que je
vous dirais de mirabel michel il a dit
qu'il avait fait mais que depuis 15 ans
il était reproché à blesser vrai qu'il
était irréprochable et michel il s'est
dit parce que
je vais le dire parce que imaginons
demain il ya peut-être des mecs qui vont
s'en servir contre eux bien évidemment
bien évidemment dans ce but il a été de
la prison c'est vrai il n'est pas blanc
bleu tout ça mais les mecs il ya
quasiment une ville et d'un horizon et
kanyana ya plein de gens et la plupart
ils se sont réinsérés
s'ils sont encore plus envie d'être
irréprochable que les autres tous les
gars qui ont fait la prison marc pessin
jeudi on est vraiment je vous dis que
énormément regarder en prison parce
qu'on on leur amène un petit peu de voix
là de de baume au coeur
appelez moi j'ai plein de potes voilà
qui se sont réinsérés qui ont passé des
années et des années derrière les
barreaux et qui aujourd'hui justement
sont dans la réinsertion
ils sont encore plus irréprochables que
nous tous sainz avait ou non c'est le
savez si loin je répète travail vous le
savez le boulot que je tiendrai tous mes
équipes avec 250 policiers bénévoles qui
travaillent au contact de ses enfants
des quartiers pour renouer le dialogue
entre jeunes police pour moi c'est un
c'est un échec total
c'est un travail je vais ramer comme un
malade pour revenir sur le terrain il
expliqué aux jeunes ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi ça s'est passé chez les
terribles prononcer la police en tir
s'est dit merci